um what else has been going on
um you know oh speaking of death
i loved watching the grammys did you
watch any part of it
um
i watched uh
no yeah i did i watched a little bit of
it i watched like some like i don't know
somebody's performance i forget nothing
like of
substance did you i tune in
uh just in time for the vigil okay you
know so they honor um
you know drama from foo fighters
nice sorry whatever you just responding
to thomas right now yeah and he really
got under your skin
you're [ __ ] lit right now
not lit angry
never mind all good blood boiling sorry
no there was a potential dog emergency
but we're fine no okay
yeah you're gonna have to let chili take
out thomas
yeah that's yeah yeah
come on over bro be aware of dog yeah
yeah no we had a we had like a mobile
groomer come to the place
whoa and uh she was like the van's not
there anymore it's like jesus [ __ ] nice
yeah that's kind of scary damn
mobile it was a vein it was just like a
white van it said it had a piece of
paper on the outside said mobile
grooming
mobile groomer is that not just a really
popular youtuber
[Laughter]
is that not a discord moderator
i thought that was a
different thing
just on the phone
what you're doing man just
yeah i'm just in my furry
talking to the nine-year-olds
he's good though
yeah okay he's chilling yeah he's
cleaned up good boy
i love him i bit the groomer good
did he actually yeah good yeah good boy
yeah
i love letting ollie's hair get like
really scraggly because he just starts
to get this einstein look yeah like his
chest gets all [ __ ] up in his ears
he'll just be looking at me like you're
gonna
you're gonna help me out do some [ __ ]
about this yeah i got [ __ ] grinch
[ __ ] a cut dude his feet literally look
like the grinch like just all furry and
weird
and then all elena and i do is make fun
of him we're like ah you stink look at
your grinch feet and he's like you made
me like this
like you gremlin
love you though
anyways um yeah so i tuned into the
grammys just in time for the vigil okay
so did they honor
um
well that's what was making me laugh was
they had
they spread it out between recognizable
artists you know there's like bismarck
in there and
uh you know
i don't know his name drummer from the
foo fighters
what's his name three two
max verstappen
no no it's white card preserved
i sh no what
your white card if you don't know the
drummer of the foo fighters we're gonna
have to take it from here
the global community is going to take
your white card if you don't know the
driver then what am i going to be
you what is it taylor
taylor hawkins yeah yeah you'll be
undecided you'll have to wait for the
next
racial prize and see
what you get selected as
you know
you're you'll you'll be in the racial
purgatory yeah
yeah you're gonna have to take that's
just funny because
uh learn to fly was the first song i
ever learned how to play on the drums
well ever
and you don't even know the name of your
literal
savior yeah damn taylor well now i know
it i mean i did know it i just forgot it
so they they start with taylor hawkins
and then and then you know they start
honoring really notable like business
managers okay and a rs random writers i
thought that was really weird yeah it
was just funny because they were taking
pictures that are clearly taken in like
the 90s and you're like
all right
who's this guy yeah
not that you need to be known it's
actually kind of cool they just take
strangers they're like this guy passed
well yeah but they didn't they also
brought out
like current alive ones like you know
stylists and stuff like that yeah you
not see that part no like they would
bring him out on stage to like uh
introduce like you know the certain
person who's who's announcing their
award or whatever and they'd be like or
or the person like performing
like her
her stylist i think got it came out on
stage or her like i don't know her pr
person or something like that and was
like
just you know said some really nice
things about her and then she was like
and now performing at the you know 2022
grammys my boss
her
like they made all of them say my boss
oh it's a little weird right i didn't
catch that yeah i yeah i thought it was
like a little bit weird
yeah that is tough like not my
collaborator not my what my boss who who
wrote that
who chose them to say my i don't know
that's what i'm saying and did they
think it was like sort of like an
empowering thing it was like weird
well
um yeah no so i just tuned in when they
just honored a bunch of dead people
um and it's fine you know i'm not trying
to disrespect them
uh however
i loved how immediately after seeing
that it
i'm watching on hulu so there's ads it
went to a pneumonia ad
i watched like all these people i'm like
wait a minute for pneumonia it was like
something
it was like like a pneumonia treatment
or like they're promoting it to raise
awareness for yeah
yeah pneumonia is sickest lung disease
literally
it's disgusting
no it was just hella big pharma ads like
just trying to treat
conditions and symptoms like man
thoughtful
you know
did you just watch the vigil of all the
people passing
here are a series of things that here's
here's how you could pass yeah
literally
and then you come back into that and
it's like now
silk sonic
yeah they cleaned up eh yeah yeah
hey
is it are they good are they good are
you kidding
have you never [ __ ] before
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] a silk sonic
it's silk sonic it's like beautiful
silky vocals dude that no mars goes to
your dick really bruno mars
and anderson pacquiao yeah i understand
anderson pack i understand i understand
that bruh
i know you know what cocaine smells like
that music should be hitting a part of
your soul where you're just like your
nose starts itching like that's what
should happen with that music you want
to do coke to the music yeah dude or
[ __ ] to it both
they don't really mix that well doesn't
matter
it's like you want to do one or the
other gotcha it's like you want to do
one and then let the knight fade and
then you know you might hit a little
pick-me-up and then just like oh yeah
you know
whichever one
happens first oh god i gotta give it a
chance then yeah you do yeah
come on i'm just sad dude i think mgk
got snubbed
careful
he might come up on this ship and slap
the [ __ ] out of us yeah that's true
that's a good point i will duck yeah
i'll try to duck the first one thanks
dude that's what a good friend does yeah
lets me get hit
i mean he could try to get both of us
he's a tall guy yeah
i said i'm ducking
you